i'm going to talk to you a little bit
about data structures
which as it turns out are really
complicated
i don't know if you know this but they
are
i was not aware of quite how complicated
they were going into this
and we'll see uh maybe a couple of ways
of making them simpler and more
relatable and
getting a more intuitive understanding
of what's going on
and then we'll look at some pretty
pictures for the rest of the talk
or at least some pictures okay
so i said data structures are
complicated um
a lot of that complexity is is
accidental complexity
uh you probably all know the difference
between accidental complexity which is
kind of unnecessary an inherent
complexity
and i figured you did so the quotes up
there
aren't actually because i'm introducing
a new term those are actually scare
quotes
while i was researching this talk i
uncovered evidence
of a vast international conspiracy
going back decades whose sole purpose
seems to be
to obfuscate data structures and their
terminology
so that folks like you and i won't be
able to understand them
so i'll give you an example of that one
you know easy breakdown in data
structures is between abstract data
structures which are an
api it's just a list of operations
like a protocol or a type class or an
abstract class and the implementation
right and we would never confuse the api
with the implementation we just wouldn't
do that
so let's see how we fare with data
structures by playing a little game
that i like to call uh abstract or
concrete
so you're gonna have to raise your hand
quite a bit for this one um
i've given this to over a hundred
developers uh
every one of them has gotten at least
one of these wrong and some of the most
experienced have gotten all of them
wrong so there's no shame here at all
i'm i'm going to call out a data
structure and then i'll ask you whether
it's abstract
raise your hand and then i'll say
concrete raise your hand okay ready
so here we go how about a stack is that
abstract
okay or is that concrete
okay good uh so that is abstract it's
two operations
push and pop we need both of those
operations to be a stack and we've got
different implementations that can
fulfill that
so let the record show it was maybe an
80 20 split there i can't see everyone
clearly though
actually let's get a baseline who knows
what a persistent data structure is
okay wow a lot of you that's great maybe
i can speed through those slides
um and who has heard the phrase data
structure before
good okay so we're at about 90
uh of you are playing along that's
excellent so how about a linked list
is that abstract or is that
concrete okay that is concrete
it defines an actual in-memory structure
for the data it has performance
implications
but it also gives us operations that can
fulfill different apis
so how about a queue is that abstract
or is it queue concrete
okay uh so yes uh a queue is abstract
you're catching on this is
excellent um how about a list just a
plain old list is that abstract
or is that concrete yeah
so a list is abstract um
it defines a few operations we need to
be able to probably append and prepend
and
then we'd like to take a head and a tail
or something right
so how about an array is that abstract
a few of you is that concrete many more
of you
and ray is actually both so you're all
wrong
uh an array is is uh
essentially a list with random access on
it
uh random access operation and it's also
the data structure that fulfills it so
this is yet
another way that uh that they are
working very hard to confuse you
uh there's a whole bunch more of these
i'm gonna skip through them now for the
in the interest of time but this is a
really fun party game that you can play
with your friends and it
it gets harder later on so let me give
you some quick rules of thumb
to distinguish between these two um uh
generic terms are abstract so if you
have a term like a tree or a graph
or a map or set or a bag those are all
abstract
except there's some irregular cases
these are not all of them you just have
to memorize them
i'm sorry so
if you have adjectives that tends to
imply that you're dealing with a
concrete data structure
unless you have too many adjectives like
a self-balancing binary search tree
i think for a minute don't answer but
think for a minute about
whether that's abstract or concrete
or you have too few adjectives right
priority queue is a particularly nasty
one because
that has an adjective in front of a an
abstract data structure it sounds like
it should be concrete
and the most common implementation of
this is a heap which sounds like it
should be abstract
and so people use the term heap to mean
priority queue and they use the term
priority q to mean heap
which uh you know i mean you're wrong
but you're only a little bit wrong and
it's it's okay there's no there's no
shame there
but these are different things okay and
now you know that they're different
things
um if it has the creator's name in it
then it is definitely concrete there are
no exceptions
always in fact we can relax this rule a
little bit and say if it's got a proper
name in it at all then it's concrete
even if that proper name is just
like a historical figure or
i haven't looked up there yet there's
supposed to be more of a margin on the
side but that's okay my slides are not
beautiful anyway
um if it's a historical figure or it
happens to be the the inventor's
daughter or it's just an acronym that
isn't even a proper name at all but
happens to be patricia then it's
concrete no exceptions
none um
right so self-balancing binary circuitry
uh
data structures form these families of
kind of refinement and improvement over
time
if the root note of that family like a
heap or a tree with an eye
who says who pronounces true with an eye
tree
like five people who pronounces it try
that's good try is a much better way i
does anyone pronounce it tree with an
eye with finger quotes
it's like just me okay um
so if your root note of this family tree
is concrete
then you're in luck because any time
you're talking about
a try you're definitely talking about a
concrete data structure and it's easy to
tell the difference
if your root node is neither concrete
nor
abstract if it's if it's nothing like a
self-balancing binary search tree then
you're in trouble because
you might be talking about one of the
particular implementations in this
collection or you may be talking about
the entire collection or you may be
talking
about the api that you've abstracted
from
the operations that are common among the
elements of the collection
and so the answer to is it abstract or
concrete it's just
it's complicated it depends on context
so another way we can break these down
is whether they're persistent or
ephemeral
about half of you know what persistent
data structures are already so i'll go
through this fairly quickly
ephemeral is just a fancy word for not
persistent
uh ephemeral data structure is just a
moment in time
um i think i have time to give you my
lego example okay
so uh if you buy a set of legos and you
build a lego castle
then at the end you've got a lego castle
and you don't know anything about its
past
you just know what it is at the moment
and it's a perfectly fine lego castle
that's ephemeral
if you buy a bunch of sets of legos and
on the first one you take out one lego
and put it on a little pedestal and from
the second box you take out two legos
and
connect them together and put them on a
pedestal and then third one
when you get to the end you've got a
lego castle and you've got all of the
history laid out
that's a persistent data structure now
this is an incredibly expensive way to
get
a persistent data structure obviously
because you've got to buy a lot of sets
of legos
and it takes you a long time to put them
together so you have both space
and time issues
expenses but we can actually do better
than that we don't have to deal with
regular legos we can use magical legos
and there's one weird trick that you
need to know that lets you get from
regular legos to magical legos and i'll
show you that in a moment
we can also improve on this though we
can talk about fully persistent data
structures
so here we're introducing a bit of 90s
surfer slang
into our data structure terminology i'm
fully stoked
i'm fully persistent i was going to do a
surfer accent but
i tried it and it was just terrible um
so with the fully persistent data
structure we can take any item in our
history
and build on it and we also get a fully
persistent data structure so we can not
only
read our history we can also take an
item from it and begin building on it
another way of thinking of this is that
we could all get a lego castle
and we all have our little lego castle
and we start building on it
right and if i happen to
see your lego castle and i like it more
than mine i can chuck mine and grab
yours and use it
instead of mine and that's a very nice
property to have and we can do this with
with our one weird trick by sharing the
base legos that we use and i can copy
yours without actually paying the
expense of it
so now uh now our conspiracy is back to
its old tricks
they're introducing archaic english the
word confluence of course
is where two rivers meet all of us know
that
but this is not obvious at all what
confluently persistent means it just
means that we can
take one of those branches and merge it
back in
so if you're
if i like your lego structure better
than i like my lego castle but i like
some of the features of my lego castle i
don't have to throw mine away i can take
your lego castle merge it with mine
and start building on that new lego
castle that's a wonderful property to
have
so what does this remind you of
yes so the next time you're at a party
and someone is talking about confluently
persistent data structures
say to them oh you mean like get uh
hilarity will ensue in fact you can walk
away at that point and come back like 20
minutes later and they'll still be going
on about this right it's amazing
but but they really are pretty much
exactly like it it's a great example
of the types of options that these data
structures give you
okay so here's our one weird trick we
make a tree
what we want is a list of numbers for
example
but if we have a list of numbers and we
want to change one of those
then we have to copy the entire list of
numbers
and put our changed one in in order to
have persistence in order to keep track
of that history we've just got regular
legos
if we make a tree out of it by chopping
up that list into smaller lists that
point
to each other or maybe we can make a try
and put all of the values at the bottom
then we can do this thing where we walk
down the tree
make a new copy of just the little sub
list down here
and then make pointers back up that
take only login time and log in extra
space to give you persistence this is
amazing
as it turns out trees are also really
nice for parallelism
guys steele gave a talk here a few years
back about using trees instead of lists
because of parallelism benefits i
suggest you watch it it's really good
okay so we've got consequences for being
concrete
uh time consequences space consequences
space
time implications there's a whole bunch
of stuff in here
and so what we end up with is these huge
charts and graphs and tables this is a
tiny slice
of a tiny slice of the data structures
right i mean
you're not supposed to be able to read
this but you're essentially comparing
operations on one
access to data structures
concrete implementations on another axis
and then you're
you know in theory going off in a third
dimension and looking at all the
different
performance and spatial implications
this is terrible
right how do we how do we make this
relatable i'm staring at this
mountain of data and suddenly it hits me
baseball baseball is the answer
so this is from a newspaper 100 years
ago they had the same problem this is
one game
right one game between two teams in a
season that had i don't know hundreds of
games
what's an order of magnitude estimate
for games 162.
wow that's much better than an order of
magnitude estimate thank you
so imagine this times 162 times
various seasons
with actually a lot more stats in there
right so how do we make this relatable
well obviously
we make baseball cards out of it right
so i suggest to you
that the answer here to make data
structures relatable
is to make data structure cards
now this is my original implementation
uh in photoshop
and comic sans um
my partner in crime henry faber was
reviewing my slides late last night and
he said no no
no i'm not going to let you burn their
eyeballs out
uh so he re-implemented these for me in
a much
nicer form using the premier uh 20th
21st century uh typing tool
omnigroffle um
so here we have our stack it's got a
push and pop operation like we talked
about
here we've got a linked list um and so
we can compare these together
and we can see that uh indeed a linked
list makes a really good stack
it's got fast push and pop operations
which is exactly what we want
so what if we take a cue and compare
that to a linked list well
that's not so good anymore and
so you can start to think about maybe
rules emerging
for game play with these cards right
and trying to put them together in ways
that actually
give you nice properties and fulfill
things so maybe you lose a turn here
because
your shifting is going to be well in
this case it's going to be quite dire
if you have a fully persistent linked
list so
maybe you lose two turns if you have a
tail pointer and you allow mutation then
you lose your persistence
but you gain the ability to fulfill this
quickly but that's a different card
right that's a different data structure
that's part of the expansion pack
okay so we could have a doubly linked
list that actually fulfills our queue
quickly but it's ephemeral
or ephemeral
that was my fault i sent henry the text
for these also very late last night
so our doubly linked list is ephemeral
and it mutates
which probably causes some type of
effect in our
game that we're imagining um
but it makes a dandy cue so if you can
handle
those properties then this is a great
way to go
here's a batch cue which is a nice way
of doing a cue
persistently and i want you to remember
this one
most of the others you can kind of let
slide by keep this in your head
we're going to have two stacks we're
going to push onto one stack and pop off
the other stack
and when our popping stack gets empty
we're going to pop
the first item off of the push stack and
push it onto our pop stack and just
reverse it
right and then that will be our new pop
stack and we've got our push dock
raise your hand if you're familiar with
this already
okay raise your hand if you're not
familiar with this and my explanation
made sense
okay good that's that's much better than
i expected actually
great um so we've got some nice
properties here we're amortized and
we're
that's not a nice property actually
we've got a bad property which is that
we're amortized which kills our hard
real-time guarantees so what that means
is that when we go to pop
every now and then we're going to have
to do this big shifting operation
but if you think about an item going in
it undergoes four operations it gets
pushed it gets popped
uh it gets pushed again and then it gets
popped again so we are constant time
over the long span
but we're amortized which means that
we're gonna occasionally have to pay a
big cost
at a certain moment so we'll have this
uh if you're doing a hard real-time
system or something like that
you can't really use things like this so
you can modify the data structure a
little which would be a different card
and end up with better properties for
this if you're staying around for racket
con they've got like
12 versions of this there's like a
physicist queue and a
banker's queue a chemist cue maybe an
astronaut q i don't know there's all
kinds of them
so this is a deck
which confusingly often has a u and an e
on the end of it so it's
dq which is one of the other operations
that you can do on a deck
but then some smart person decided to
dequeue a few up
a few letters off of the end of it and
call it a deck
and this is this is just another example
of
the ambiguity and uh yeah
okay so uh our doubly linked list is a
great deck
how do we get a deck that is persistent
so i was going to talk about two three
finger trees
which make dandy decks i'm going to just
skip ahead and show you
a terrible hasher in that tree slide i
apologize henry didn't get a chance to
remake this one
hashtag map tries are lovely a try means
we've got everything down at the bottom
in this case we're walking down with
sections of the key so we take
five bits of the key that we're looking
for
after hashing it that's the hashing part
and then we take the first five bits of
that hash and we
look at where to go from there so that
five bits gives you an array of size 32.
i'm saying a lot of words without really
explaining them very well here are the
things that i want you to remember about
this
they're very useful data structures and
they involve arrays of size 32.
so keep those two things in your head
and maybe we'll be okay in the next
section
okay um hey this is really good
um i'm at 20 minutes now and
usually when i've practiced this i've
been at 40 minutes now so
this gives us much more time for the
next section which i'm excited about
so the question is i've shown you a
whole bunch of different data structures
um and maybe some ways to think about
them and classify them and get a little
more
make them a little more relatable but
how do we
how do we deal with the data that's
already in our systems
or you know maybe you have a library
that has some data structures in it and
you don't quite know what they are
well one way to do that is to you know
take a snapshot of that data every now
and then and dig through it and try to
figure out what they're doing another
way to do it the more obvious way is to
look at the code
right so you go into the code and you
try to figure out what they're doing
with this data structure and what the
properties are there
so i'm going to show you a different way
of
trying to do that
and we'll be doing it in javascript
which has some pros and cons
let's see can you see
this is that visible
i bet you can see that okay
all right so let's say we've got a
really simple data
thing this is just an array of size
three
and we'd like to render that
so what are we looking at over here this
is
um let's actually make x bigger
we're going to take some sequential
numbers we'll take 88 of them
88 of them and we'll render that
so our render is really simple it's just
a
pipeline that kind of flattens things
and then it
colorizes them evaluates them and then
colorizes them
and then kind of pushes them up here on
our display so here are the important
parts
that you need to know for this right now
we're going to display values based on
their
or display colors rather that correlate
to these values
so one is up here it's red and 88 is
down here it's green
and there's a black bit on either side
and that's because
when we flatten these things out we want
to be able to see what's inside of them
in terms of their
kind of steps that we're taking up and
down
so we're going to color those as well
we're going to color black in particular
so here we've got a bunch of black dots
because we're kind of
walking up and down okay
so what if we make a y and we'll fill it
with
some random numbers uh because that'll
be fun
and then we're just going to say
array.observe
and we're going to ask our browser to
observe y
and we'll feed it a function which is
just render y
and this almost fits on the screen oh i
got it right good
maybe we'll move this over slightly okay
and now we can say
y uh push um and we'll just push a
random number into it
and uh we'll do that a couple more times
and then maybe we'll say y
shift and pop something off and so we
can actually as we're mutating y
uh we're in mutational land as we're
mutating y we're watching it happen on
the screen
so what if we combine these two
operations together and we push in a
random number
and then we also shift off so this is
what it ends up looking like you can see
down here at the bottom maybe i'll do
this a few more times
actually this is really annoying so
we'll do this instead good okay so
as i push this magical button that i
just created
you can see items going in on the bottom
that's the new colors that are appearing
and items going off the top
and you can tell that it's working as a
cube because it doesn't increase in size
it's just fixed
okay does everyone understand that
okay i think i've belabored that enough
let's look at a slightly more
interesting example
this is that simple cue that we just saw
this is a trickier queue it's working as
a queue but there's some
weird stuff happening in there okay so
let's see if we can figure out what the
algorithm for tricky q
is just by looking at this visualization
okay
so the first thing that we notice is
that it is in fact a queue this is not
increasing in size we've got new things
coming in on the bottom and we've got
stuff leaving on the top we can also see
that it's quite flat
because we only walk down once that's
this black line up here
and we walk back up once okay so far so
good
it's exactly like our cue but then we've
got these spans
like here can you see the pointer okay
the mouse
yeah okay um we've got these spans like
this first one here
where nothing is happening almost
nothing is happening
um so we must not be pushing or popping
at that point
and we've got these red things appearing
here
so i guess every once in a while we're
pushing a particular value in
at this particular level maybe this is
20 pixels in i've zoomed the pixels out
so they're
like five by five squares uh just for
this part of the demonstration
and then we've got the same thing
happening down here with the blue we're
pushing something in there does that
make sense
okay what if i push this button what
happens now
well uh we've got these purple things
appearing and they seem to appear
fairly regularly so
i must be pushing some values in every i
don't know 10 values or something
okay so maybe we've
so i i actually know what this algorithm
is since i wrote it
and that's exactly what it is now let's
look at something that i haven't looked
at the code for
didn't write and haven't looked at the
data of there
are two different persistent
data structure libraries for javascript
there's actually a lot of them but a
classic one is mori that takes
closure scripts data structures and
brings them over and a new one
is facebook's immutable js so
i want to just look at some pictures of
those data structures
and see if we can actually get some
insight so let's play through
this is zoomed out now so one pixel
really is one pixel
we'll play through this q a bit
and then we'll stop it and see if we can
figure out what's going on
okay so the first thing we notice is
these black bars here
we're pushing values in along here and
then here we start
popping them off so we're populating the
queue and then we're popping things off
this is
not really a cue it's just their vector
implementation but i'm using it as a
queue
okay so we notice this banding here with
these thick black bars
this seems to indicate that we've got
these size 32 arrays so they're probably
using
using a hash array map tree try under
the hood
we also have these darker areas here
and the darker areas indicate that we've
stepped down a level
so these things are happening further
down in our
data structure tree than these things
and we can see that we kind of
accumulate into one of these
and then we place it over here which is
pop it up a level
so this must be some kind of tail that
they're using as an accumulator and then
when it gets to size 32 we pop that up
here
we also have this other interesting
feature
which is this bar at the top
and all four of these four or five of
these pixels
have the same oh except this bottom one
so i don't know if you can see this but
there's a solid
color line here which is some type of
metadata that isn't changing
and then everything else starts off at
the same value so maybe we'll guess that
that's zero
and then flows through so we're
increasing increasing increasing
and then suddenly we switch over and
this one cuts back to maybe zero
and then these two start doing something
else
i've stared at these a lot longer than
you have
so i'm giving you a guided tour but
hopefully this is making a little bit of
sense
and then this weird jaggedness down here
correlates with two things one is this
little bump
when we run out of
one of our buckets here uh then we make
a jump
so we run out of the bucket here and we
have our new tail starting here
so we finished our tail we make a new
bucket out of that tail
this is our new full bucket we can see
the tails are still a little darker down
here
and then we start a new tail but just
after we start that
we are shifting up here i want to show
you one more feature on this and then
we'll look at maury's version
which is this little tiny bump right
here and it seems like a glitch
essentially we're pushing a new pixel
down here this colored bit
but up here we're not popping anything
off so
what what is going on there it seems
like something has just gone awry that
every single time i run this
this happens i have no idea why because
i wanted to come in
just like you fresh and not having
looked at the code here
but there is something interesting
happening maybe eight
steps into using this as a queue after
we start popping
and i'd love to know what that is all
right so let's look at moore's version
okay so pretty much the same thing so
far this is good uh we understand what's
happening we're loading in a tail
uh into these buckets we've got a little
more metadata up here
and then oh dear
uh so that's a lot different
that that's that's my alarm telling me
that uh
i should have moved on to this point by
now which i have
so that's good um okay
so oh does that affect no it doesn't
it's only for me
but it makes me happier so
okay so we've got some metadata here and
that doesn't seem to ever change
okay that's fine
we've got a bunch more metadata up here
otherwise this seems to be more or less
the same as the facebook
version that we were seeing but then
something really weird happens
so right here is where we start popping
i happen to know that because we're
popping at the same point as
the facebook one which is like
200 values or something and as soon as
we start popping
we get this really weird effect where
this part of the data structure
is now here but we're not actually
popping anything off
and then we've got this other part of
the data structure that's accumulating
things
so what does this remind you of a
batched queue right
we looked at a data structure that
worked as a queue that used two stacks
and so we're we're building up one thing
here
and then as soon as we start popping
that thing
goes here nothing comes off of it oddly
enough
uh and then we start building up a
second thing
and then something weird happens here
and then we start building up another
thing and it looks like if we look at
these colors
that this actually pops up here at this
point
so we've got some other strange features
this looks like i don't know is that
metadata or is that a copy of something
it's hard to tell
but we've got this weird area in the
middle
some of the metadata from up here seems
to move down to here so that's fine we
won't worry about that it looks like
it's maybe size information it's
increasing
so what what is this middle chunk well
this
is exactly this and this is exactly this
so these are pointers
they're a little they're shaded a little
bit they're they're darker because
they're one level down in the tree
uh than this stuff that they're pointing
to so what it looks like is happening is
that
we're taking a bucket here and putting a
pointer to it here and then probably
this is maybe 32 across and 32 high so
we're popping things off
and then we're doing that again and
doing that again and doing that again
and then when we run out
we get this strange effect where
like our last little oh i see that's
what this is this is the previous tail
that's left over here getting copied up
here
okay i didn't actually know that um
so here's our little tail bit and
so that's why this chunk is shifted up
and then when we're done we just throw
away the entire thing right
so this is actually really nice because
this in some ways has some garbage
collection implications where we're
collecting each of these buckets every
time we get done with them
here we're only collecting the buckets
once when when that entire stack is done
and we just
collect it all at once right instead of
popping things off
this is probably because in javascript
shifting things off is a really
expensive operation
okay is this making sense
kind of ish all right let's look at
maps so
here's a random map in the facebook
system
without the black bars and here's the
same map
in the mori system
and these look pretty similar
like this one's growing a little more
slowly but it's going to be hard to tell
the difference
between them it looks like this data and
this data maybe correlates somehow
maybe this is metadata because it's all
one color i don't know
let's look at these with the black bars
on
that's growing really fast okay let's
look at maury with the black bars on
it doesn't necessarily oh that's
interesting
so we've got this jump here that clearly
indicates that after we get to
i don't know maybe that's 32 then we
jump and do something different
um so the fact that this one grows so
quickly in our picture
doesn't necessarily indicate that it's
using more space
because we're only showing numbers and
jumps up here but
it is they they are very different data
structures now right
this one seems to be using our old
friend the ham tee
and this one is i don't know what
there's lots and lots and lots of little
tiny sub-objects in here
um okay
let's look at this sequentially
so before i was just inserting random
numbers uh the keys
are strings so it's the number with a
letter appended
now we're putting numbers in
sequentially and we see
really distinct banding patterns
happening
so we can guess a few things one we can
guess that this is the data in this
middle section
and that the data is being hashed in
some
curious fashion that keeps changing
over time uh we've got a lot of metadata
up here
if we turn on the black bars i won't do
that so let's see
mori sequentially adding things we've
got our strange little
starting point up here again
but we're growing in a much different
fashion
right so whereas these are clearly
banded and you can see that they're
probably using a modulo operation for
the hash of some kind
here
we're growing in an entirely different
fashion
and it looks like i don't know
oh and we're starting to get some
banding where we skip around
let's turn on the black bars for a
moment
and we see we've got these big wide data
containers
this is probably our hashrate map tree
at these banding points
having new elements added to it
and if we try this one sequential again
then we
slow down our computer a lot and
get just this very linear progression
because none of this is changing at all
so i can't tell you exactly
what the implementations are under the
hood but i can we can already tell
a lot about these data structures just
from looking at these
pictures that are being generated in an
incredibly simplistic fashion
really in some ways the most simplistic
fashion that we possibly could right and
it's maybe five pages of javascript to
generate this which means
if you're in a more expressive language
it's going to be half a page right
if you happen to be using j it's
probably a one-liner
we're just flattening things down and
then
throwing it up there based on value but
we don't have to do that we could
show a difference between the previous
state and this state
we could take into account data locality
uh we could perform a discrete fourier
transform
over the data that we're showing and
maybe get like a three-dimensional image
so we start to see
how frequent the updates the different
areas of the data structure are if you
have this running in a real application
i think that would be
quite revealing of the actual utility of
your data structure in your application
um and it you know again this is in
javascript so we're limited at
the bottom we've just got objects and
arrays and they're both implemented
however the browser engine wants to
implement them
but in your language of choice you could
do this and peek inside your running
systems and
actually see what's going on inside
there at a level that
i think would be really interesting to
explore
so back to the slides
and we count to three while this slowly
does its thing
okay uh remember your rules of thumb
they're very helpful for parties uh data
structure cards
very exciting and uh visualize your data
because
you never know what you're going to find
in there all right i'm down
i think i've exhausted all my time so
i'll take questions offline
thank you